[Musique]
cela fait deux cent quinze jours qu'elle
n'avait pas vu son mari
ces retrouvailles émouvantes ont eu lieu
dans une résidence médicalisée en
floride
leur dernière rencontre remonte au mois
de mars joseph avait dû être opéré de la
jambe et suivre un programme de
rééducation loin de son épouse
une trentaine de seniors est déjà sur la
piste
[Musique]
tango madison
valls il danse de tous moi je sais que
j'adore jouer dans les bistrots gg j'ai
joué j'ai fait hugo bistrot est ce que
j'adorais ça j'ai même violent des
boucheries et comme là maintenant nos
créateurs vont être fermés je me dis
pourquoi pas dire oui ou même dans la
rue l homme viril quel homme de poigne
tranquille c'est beau c'est beau vivent
les suhard de kendo et puis je vais
mettre un petit rap l'on doit alors si
vous voulez que ce que voulaient comme
texte et puis je vais jouer dans la rue
mais je pense que nous touche devons
réagir de cette façon là et le bistrot
c'est vraiment un lieu de lien
extraordinairement importante certes une
tradition française
c'est extrêmement important ils ont
entre 55 et 95 ans
on apprend beaucoup de tension
[Musique]
pour éviter l'ennui
à 100 mais tu commences à moi je les
vois faire comme ça avec leurs mains
désolé quand et cérébral le toucher de
la main
il est puissant voici la carte des
métropoles où un couvre-feu a été
instauré les vingt-et-une communes de la
métropole de clairement auvergne
pourrait bientôt être concernée par une
telle mesure le taux d'incidence c'est à
dire le nombre de nouveaux cas pour
100000 habitants sur les sept derniers
jours dépasse les seuils d'alerté fixé
par le gouvernement
il est même très préoccupant chez les
plus de 65 ans on va faire quoi
alors elle intègre les gestes barrière
dans son ambiance festive de coups de
cornes de brume et toute l'assemblée
doit se désinfecter les mains au gel
hydro alcoolique elle le fait toutes les
heures j'ai réfléchi comment on pouvait
faire pour prévenir tout le monde que le
poids de pointe à près de quatre
français sur dix seraient retirés tissot
ont refusé net de se faire vacciner
comment est ce qu'on vient à bout de ce
scepticisme de cette méfiance de cette
défiance sur tout ce qui vient du
médical de la recherche en expliquant
c'est terrible parce que pour pour
diffuser une fausse nouvelle
c'est enfantin il faut suffit de
quelques secondes et pour la démolir il
faut très longtemps on se sent
intouchable et que le jour où sa vague
arrivait à nos grands parents on va
sentir vraiment très très mais la
jeunesse la fleur de l'âge
les vingt ans font que on a forcément
envie de faire le petit truc interdit de
sortie veut jouer avec les règles et
tout mais je pense qu'on a tous
conscience que c'est pas bien
découvrez soirée au bar à la maison un
dvd exceptionnelle pour continuer à
vivre vos apéros barre malgré le couvre
feu depuis votre salon
2h30 d'image pour retrouver l'ambiance
des pubs
revivez la joie d'attendre 25 minutes au
comptoir avant de vous faire servir une
bière tiède à 12 euros
dans cette ambiance de fête nous
rencontrons un client plutôt inattendue
c'est toi
[Musique]
alors là raquel la différence c'est
qu'ils en parlent mais c'est intéressant
merci d'identité par exemple son ami
ambages oublie dire il était enceinte la
secrétaire d'état au numérique un jour
de ma prendre de haut bah oui on a eu
une conversation toi et moi bah oui
j'étais dit je voulais accueilli ici les
règles ici oui mais avec les données par
les sur tout le monde on vous aime
beaucoup mais vous n'êtes pas sinon je
suis fou que tu aimes tu n'en respecte
c'est vrai les gens rigolaient c'est du
délire ou quoi c'est plus de la loose il
a cessé
c'est incroyable ça a dépassé les bornes
de la limite ça et s'il vous plaît
respectez moi également
le gars il oui j'en ai commencé
sérieusement à des choses et wim à
respecter période autour de la table et
je suis pas le seul à le dire c'est pas
vrai je suis pas le seul à le dire tu
utilises ton magistrats ni van houtte
est lourd mais ciblée et durant sans
avoir ras-le-bol laquelle on vous a
laissé parler toute la soirée
à chaque fois vous êtes hors sujet si
vous en avez ras le bol quitter
l'émission america's pour dire je me
suis retenu d'avoir des flatulences mais
qui ça peut être c'est déjà flatulences
ya un pas que ça existait que je vous
annonce que
je fais pas de la céramique mois chez
moi la céramique c'est des boulons des
motos du noir partout défi c'est ici tu
m'as vu ou pas avec mon bras qui pend
fait bas de la céramique en fait vous
avez tellement cher la bac brigade
tellement fier oui bon alors on
s'emballe pas il reste encore quelques
étapes à valider avant d'en arriver là
à commencer par le coup vous allez être
surpris par là cet été n'a pas goûté
tranquillement la remuée mélanger
fortement
astiquez voit ce que vous êtes déjà
sorti avec un invité de l'émission who
have eyes et l'émission d'une de vos
émissions même un anonyme - invité ou
quelqu'un est ce que vous avez dû à un
regain croche avec jean pierre pernaut
jean-pierre fardeau serait bannie je
vole pas le mari d autres oui ça m'est
arrivé non quoi avec un mec de ces bons
choix oui un ascète c'est mon choix
oui le message le plus improbable de
fans que tu ai reçus sur instinct le
message le plus improbable que j'ai eu
c'est une femme qui m'a proposé un
mariage à trois elle est déjà mariée
elle en a déjà parlé avec son mari son
mari n'était pas contre un peu bizarre
bizarre
des gens bizarres et ville mercier mais
attendez-vous on peut pas le couper sans
montage parce que je vais avoir les jeux
parle pas de ma vie privée dans les
rêves et dont le couple rien on m'avait
déjà assez cooper la descente
merci dégueulasse a commencé le monde la
fin après avoir tout gagné
on a passé des moments de vie des gueux
l'annoncé j'ai passé des plus mauvais
moment je mens était génial merci à tous